so you have to be know where you are you
have to know where you're going and then
you have to fill
your own coding with that stuff and
start building the infrastructure for
the future
[Music]
thomas chandler thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders how are
you
i'm great it's my pleasure thank you for
inviting me
of course where are you calling from i'm
currently in berlin
um the weather
the weather's getting chilly here and
we're looking forward to hopping back to
costa rica because we
tend to hop between berlin and costa
rica
is that for weather reasons because of
the because of opposite
um you know seasons my wife is from
costa rica
so um beautiful yeah
very very nice thomas uh you know we
only have 20 minutes your journey is so
fascinating
and in that you know if you just look at
the things you're doing it
looks it almost looks like it's a it's
it's exactly the journey that i
that are fitting for this show these
non-linear journeys
that are not just about a specific
profession or a specific company but
they're more holistically about
what what is our purpose and and who are
we as human beings and
i'm not gonna do enough service to your
journey if i try to give an outline
myself
but but i'd love to to hear from you a
little bit about what
what you're excited about then maybe
even take me back a few years about the
different things you've done
and then i'd love to culminate also in
in the most recent company
uh dullardy and and the funny uh thing
that we talked about
the delegate order
[Music]
all right so what i'm what i'm
always um excited about and what drives
me
is um trying to contribute towards
making the planet a good
place and i say goods
intentionally and i borrow it from from
isabellande who
once pointed to the fact that
in increment is while necessary
um never an end
we have to never forget that um
we are need to head towards a good state
and not towards it so just a better
state
and the way i like to bring this home is
um if you
imagine um 14
000 children under the age of five dying
every day
for from preventable causes
that would be better because at the
moment it's 15
000 right but it should be zero
and that's good right we so we had need
we should not never forget where we're
headed and i think that's that's crucial
and having this this big why
um is um is absolutely critical and
um just yesterday my my son who's 11
years old um
surprised me um by finding
uh simon sinek's golden circle all by
himself
in preparation for a video he intends to
do
um about some future issues
yeah wow so how does this why
you know integrate into the life cycle
of an
entrepreneur a leader and
i'd love to because because this is
something that i'm personally passionate
about in my own journey of understanding
what are the types of things that i want
to be working on
things that and just yesterday i was
walking with somebody in tel aviv and we
were talking about what kind of company
do we want to build one day
and we basically said that there's two
things one we have to be intentional
about our about our what we want to
achieve
the second it has to have a positive
social impact on the world
but i'm still confused what does that
mean
yes uh i i i'm i'm continuously confused
and i i
nurture my confusion as well as my
a naive look on the world and i think
these are two crucial elements of um
trying to move towards something
meaningful um
and not becoming desperate at the state
of the world
not becoming um frustrated at the
hardships that you go through when you
build something and i think this is
deeply connected with the question of
what is the ultimate objective you're
after
and if if this is a lot bigger than
you if this is a lot further out
than you could possibly achieve
then you're probably on the right track
because
what i learned in in building businesses
all sorts of organizations of the past
more than 20 years
is that if i
don't align my current activities
with a larger goal larger than life
larger than me goal
i'm not never really sure whether i'm
doing the right thing
and i can never really judge whether
there is something that has more impact
towards the goal i want to achieve and
and i have a very specific goal and it
doesn't have to be
not everybody has to have that same goal
of trying to
contribute towards making the plan a
good place but um you can also
choose to have a goal to maximize your
personal financial profit if you wish
um but you need to have a
really clear goal that goes beyond you
have to be intentional
about it yeah yeah right so so
walk me through a little bit about the
different experiences you've accumulated
and how
that goal of yours played into those
different experiences
well i have to jump back a little bit in
time to dinner table conversations with
my family which were usually revolved
around
mainly two aspects one was existential
risk like
nuclear winter and climate chaos
and on the other hand um things like
ion channels in cells or power
microscopy
so both how old are you when you're
referring back to these dinner
conversations by the way
i would say um so consciously anything
between
7 and 14 maybe um amazing
so in in and that configured me
right so that's this this is kind of
like the task
my my parents gave us for life and it
took me a long time to
try and figure out a lot of frustration
i had to go through and to figure out
how my role could be in that
and and what i could see was always that
um money seemed to go in the wrong
direction money never seemed to go where
it should be
but more where it was exploiting more
planet than people
and in 2003 i was part of a meeting
um with the head of the central bank in
germany and the former head of central
bank from belgium and
they were there to introduce a new
complementary currency in germany
and i was there to help them build the
software for that
for political reasons this never
happened but it blew my mind anyway
and what i learned from from those
people was that
the design of a currency has
unintended emerging properties that's um
then
might be negative and our current
financial
system is has enormous unintended
emergent negative properties
um a fiat currency backed by gdp we're
not going to go into the details but
is a recipe for disaster it's it's it is
not only an invitation but a reward
system for exploitation of planet and
people
so that that's what i've been struggling
with um for the past
17 years and what i've been more and
more aligning my
activities along um to
contribute towards um a situation where
um we can get out of that gridlock of
financial capital
and broaden our perspective into other
forms of capital
um if i if i look at only financial
capital
i am i tend to
be very very limited in my view of the
world if i look at
let's say ethan roland's eight forms of
capital like social capital and
material and living and cultural and
spiritual intellectual etc
then the the equation changes
and then you can you can allow yourself
to act in
entirely different ways because you're
not only after financial capital which
is important
and to get things running and to to
to to make create more meaningful things
but um is not enough in itself
but i have to say thomas speaking to you
i feel like i'm speaking to
a you know as somebody who who goes to
india for
11 months of the year doing meditation
you know doing very spiritual things in
their day-to-day life
it also has a job but actually you're
the ceo of a company that delivers
software solutions and you're in
you're in high tech right and and i'm
finding this
you know intuitively i'm finding this
dissonance
between your profession and you what
your
your upbringing and the things you're
passionate about and i'm seeing this
distance because i just don't see enough
people like this i think it's i think
it's incredible
but i don't see enough so thank you for
that observation um
you're to the point absolutely but um i
actually think that
there is no dissonance at all it's
actually extremely congruent if you look
at
especially digital technologies and also
it gets worse with
sustainable or regenerative technologies
and what you have to do in order to
implement them successfully you have to
question
your status quo you have to question
your past
so if you go into an organization that
wants to digitize
move towards um digital transformation
in any meaningful way which is part of
what we do
and you always have to ask really
fundamental questions and this
is painful because what it reveals is
that
for the past 10 20 30 100 years your
organization has been on the wrong track
essentially you've been doing things
that
look embarrassing to everyone
right um and the only way to deal with
this
is to be very clear about yourself to
have a strong individual personal
foundation that's why
all of these journeys have to start with
individual
and this is why you're totally right um
um
i i don't go to india to to to to
try and be clear about myself um we
actually developed the framework
to help people do that because that is
of
absolute vital basis and you can do that
in your everyday life and all the time
and you can also move that into your
entire organization which
helps in the decision making so that's
what i want to focus on because i think
that you know
i'm i'm on a goal i have a personal goal
to be intentional
and i think it's an interesting goal
because i my goal is to have a goal
right i i feel that you know i'm growing
up i get to have these
really interesting experiences i meet
these really great people but i'm trying
to become intentional with my actions
and
and what i'm hearing from you is that we
need to have
more we need to have more people in
leadership positions that are
intentional about their goals and that
what you started out with is they saying
you know there are all sorts of goals
and a lot of them are are okay but you
need to be intentional about it
yeah i mean when was the last time you
weren't intentional about your dinner
right
so let's let's assume you cook a
romantic dinner
um and you you you never follow a recipe
without knowing what you're cooking
right
right all right so you know usually
people don't
go on a holiday unless they know where
they're going and why and what they're
going to
experience right right so why are people
going through their year their life
their next project their company
without really knowing where they're
going right so
so i think there's three three important
components you need to
be very clear where you are in the
vastness of
all possibilities right incredible
right that requires deep deep search
inside yourself
to paraphrase the google thing and how
do you get there
today with abundance of both good
information misinformation
and no emotion like you know the things
we're experiencing in
my generation in our day-to-day lives
whether it's at university the military
you know the streets in the city are we
we're being pulled in all sorts of
directions how can we even begin to be
intentional about what we're actually
feeling
so this is thing called the default mode
network which is
guiding 90 to 95 of your decision making
every day
and your default mode network usually
gets coded in your
first seven years of your life wow
if those people which we assume were
well intended
um they still coded you for an entirely
different world
your the rest of your capacity
your ex executive um network knows
what to do but your default mode network
pushes you back into
behaving like you always behaved and
like people were behaving 50 years ago
so you need to clear out that clutter
first right there's some techniques
of how to do that um the
the framework we've developed is called
roots roots factor.com
it's free and so anybody can
just go there and sign up amazing um
that helps you with uncluttering and
then
very important you're developing your
personal first horizon
which is necessary because once you
start uncluttering
you lose um the
let's say the hold on the current
situation of
how things are done in society because
you're
you're taking things out right you're
taking programming out so you need
new programming in and you want to be in
charge of that
if you if you aren't in charge of that
you slip into
something called a spiritual emergency
and a spiritual emergency
essentially is grab your your brain
grabbing onto anything it can
get get hold off to make sense of this
is why
there's so much conspiracy theory going
on at the moment
because at people have the strong
understanding and notion and
visceral feeling that the world is
falling apart
and they are they don't know how to how
to play a role in that
and their entire ontology is breaking
down
they have no epistemology to make sense
of this and create a neurotology for
themselves
so they fill it with conspiracy theory
so this is very crucial so you have to
be know where you are you have to know
where you're going and then you have to
fill
your own coding with that stuff and
start building the infrastructure for
the future
right it reminds me a little bit of of
you know a phenomenon that we see all
around us but especially i
i say in my own country that you have in
a radical religion
that a lot of the time from from an
outsider's
observant it almost seems like a lot of
the actions that we choose to take are
sort of to fill
it to feel a fear of the unknown and we
look for solutions and even those even
if those solutions aren't necessarily
the right ones that are not
ideal for the world if they feel
if they fill that void then then we
then we take them in and we and we adopt
them and to me that feels very dangerous
if it feels dangerous in an age where
we can have misinformation spread out
very easily and when there's
you know some ambiguity around us and
you have somebody in a leadership
position we're seeing it you know unfold
every single day right now as we're
speaking you know with what's happening
in the us
then we're seeing new ideas and new
information that is necessarily true
being adopted by people that are just
looking for answers
and and that is something that i'm
taking with me as a as i'm looking to
become
potentially as a person who might people
might want to listen to
i want to be very conscious and very
responsible with the messages that i put
out
and what's true and what's not true
that's good
um maybe maybe you might be familiar
with
robert keegan's work um he's a
developmental psychologist
and i like using his work although it's
very similar to other
developmental psychologists work he
he differentiates between three mindset
levels
uh he calls it a growth hierarchy um
in the adult life and it is important to
to note that a every human given enough
time
goes through this evolution through this
um hierarchy
um and um and that's
there is it's not a power hierarchy it's
a it's a
it's something you grow into um and it's
not
something you can buy yourself into so
the first level is the socialized
mindset
the socialized mindset is defined by you
understanding the
rules of your society and living by them
becoming a trusted member a working
member of your society
when you step out of that and you start
questioning and editing those rules you
become a self-authoring mind
and this is this is a discrete step this
is like the moment in your life when you
started
turning lines into letters right all of
a sudden you could see these
letters and you could get an idea
of what people were talking about when
they talked about
reading and then you step out of your
self-authoring mind into what's called
the self-transforming mind
and now you're looking at the heuristics
your self-authoring mind
uses to edit the socialized mind
and this is when you start reading when
you start putting
those letters into words and you cannot
unlearn that and it's a distinct
moment and it has something to do with
the complexity
of your mind wow
wow that's it i i'm just learning how
much i don't know and i've always been
fascinated by
mr college and again i have to say that
it inspires me to meet somebody who's
you know in high tech but you know
within this 20-minute conversation we
never once talked about
you know the saw the different projects
that you actually worked on and
and the impact that you've brought with
them but we talked about more
holistically what what is
what is our responsibility and one of
the things that i that i enjoyed most
was that the very first thing out of the
box that we said was
you know that you know you mentioned
your goal
and what some of your intentions into
having a positive impact on the world
but
you mentioned that every person has a
different goal or intention and one of
the most important things that we can do
for ourselves is to be
is to have that intention is to have to
declutter
and go through that process and i'm
definitely what he said it's roots
factor.com
and so i'm definitely going to check
because that's that's something that
as i'm growing a little bit older and
maturing myself and i see that
with my friends as well we're looking
for that decluttering
we're saying we were fortunate to have
these experiences and
to be learning with these amazing people
but now we're gonna have to make some
critical choices ourselves
and and with all that coloring it
becomes very very difficult
and uh some i'm definitely very thankful
for that but thomas i want to thank you
for for this wonderful conversation
before we leave
i have to ask you for three words that
you would use to describe yourself
or that somebody would use to describe
you
and in our next twenties because does it
have to be a sentence or can it be just
you're gonna you choose whatever format
you want but i do have to have this on
record that in our next 20 minute
session
you're going to be teaching myself in
the audience how to do a thai massage
which we never we didn't get to talk
about that either
yes i can i can do that yes my wife
would be happy because
she's i'll i'll do it on her then
okay so um
i'm
i'm optimistic
beyond reason i love that
optimistic beyond reason i'm gonna
i'll try to adopt that and i'll let you
know when i get there
thomas thank you thank you very very
much i really appreciate your time to do
this
and and stay safe and stay healthy you
too
[Music]